WELCOME EVERYBODY TO OUR JOBS
COMMITTEE TODAY ON AUGUST TWENTY
SEVENTH WE HAVE ONE BILL.
OUGHT TO PRESENT AND WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND CALL THE MEETING TO
ORDER.
AND WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
MEMBERS AN AUDIENCE AND I SEE
THE COUNCILS.
NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
AND THAT WITH THAT WE WILL CALL
OUR AUTHOR UP [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW.
AND YOU ARE PRESENTING S. B.
TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
COMBINATION OF THIS SPECIFICALLY
AND ALLOW ME TO BE BRIEF SO THAT
WE CAN GET TO OUR SESSION AND
TIME.
OF FIRST OFF THANK YOU EFFORT
WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE AND HAD
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS YOU KNOW THIS IS --
IN COLLABORATION AND WORKING OFF
OF THE JOINT HEARING THAT YOU'VE
ALSO HEALTH MADAM CHAIR WITH
RESPECT TO RECOGNIZING THE PORN
RELATIONSHIP ECONOMICALLY AND
CULTURALLY WITH THE PEOPLE IN
CHINA SO I WITH RESPECT THIS A
RESOLUTION.
HELPS TO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD IN THE PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC
OF CHINA AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND AS WAS NOTED WE
HAVE WORKED ON THIS ISSUE
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE WITH A
NAME INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND I
THOUGHT THAT WAS.
A VERY INFORMATIVE TO TO MYSELF
AND OTHER PEOPLE ON OUR
COMMITTEE AS FAR AS I'M NOT ONLY
THE ROBUST --
EXCHANGE WE DO ALL SO LITTLE
BITS OF INFORMATION THAT CAME
OUT OF THAT HEARING THAT --
A AS FAR AS THE TOURISM TRACK
TRAVEL ON HOW MANY AYE CHINESE A
A CONSTITUENTS.
I AND OTHER MEMBERS OF YOUR
COUNTRY LOOK LIKE TO TRAVEL HERE
AND HOW BEAUTIFUL THEY THINK OUR
COUNTRY IS SO WE WANT TO KEEP
THEM COMING.
AND SO WORK SITE ABOUT THIS DO
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS CEMENT
NEVER CERVANTES OKAY SO WITHOUT
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY HERE IN
SUPPORT OF OUR SELF.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU JEFF
LEADER WITH GTECH TECHNOLOGIES A
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I CAN SEE.
YEAH UP CLOSE SO WE SUPPORT THE
THANK YOU EVERYBODY AND THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IS THAT AT THIS
A BUSY SCHEDULE TO HOLD --
THE COMMITTEE HERE IN AND SANK
TO A I DON'T KNOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO INITIATE --
THIS IMPORTANT A RESOLUTION AT
THE SO CRUCIAL TIME OF FOLDS UP
AN ACTUAL --
CHEETAH RELATIONS SIR I BELIEVE
THAT IT IS THE RIGHT DECISION
WRITING THIS ASIAN AND RIGHT.
HEARING --
CHINA CHINA IS THE LARGEST THE
TRADING PARTNER SO --
TO LOBBYIST TO EXPORT MARKET OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO THE LARGEST
THAT LAWS SO.
ATTENDEES PEOPLE MICA CALIFORNIA
WINE -- HA
HA OF THE AGRICULTURE FOOD AND
THE IS A BOOMING MARKET.
I WILL CODDLE AND OTHERS AND
ALSO NOT JUST TO TAKE ONE
EXAMPLE TO SHOW A WHOLE WING
BEING.
AND A OF OUR TREE DID FOR
INSTANCE THE IPHONE --
I KNOW THAT THE THE HEADQUARTERS
IS HERE BEING --
TELEPHONE AND APPLE LOST A YEAR --
THING CHINA MARKET --
THE SO DID A OVER OF FIFTY ONE
OF FIVE FIFTY ONE A FIVE HUNDRED
AND TEN A LET ME SAY.
FIFTY ONE AND MEDIAN.
IPHONE IN CHINA --
FULL. 22% OF TOTAL IPHONE SO IN
CHINA.
ABOUT THE OLD LEASE AMONG TO AND
TWO THIRDS THE AYE POLL EARNED
AS THE REVENUE.
OF NEARLY.
TEN AND BEATING U. S. DAUGHTER
BUT ITS VOLUME IF NO DOT COM.
TO A IN THE BETTER TREAT.
SO THAT'S THE ONE EXAMPLE
ANOTHER EXAMPLE PACE THAT
GENERAL MOTORS CHRYSLER.
AND OTHER THE SRI HEAD BECAUSE
AUTOMOBILE COMPANIES LOST THE
ALSO LEADING IN TIME TO MARKET
IT THEY SEWED.
OVER.
BECAUSE OF THE ASSEMBLY AND IN
CHINA ALSO.
A LOT OF REVENUES.
OVER --
FIFTY BILLION.
REVENUES AND ALSO.
NEVERTHELESS TO JUST TO SAY OF
THE STARBUCKS LATEX IN THE MONTH
NUMBER --
PEOPLE --
THE LAST A HEARING YEAH WE
PARTICIPATE --
IN THE GENEROUS SOMEBODY THE
NUMBER OR FOR STARBUCKS OPENED
IN CHINA IS.
A TWO THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED BUT
TODAY'S THE THREE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND THERE IT GOES DAIS
TO OPEN.
AND SIX THOUSAND STARBUCKS --
EIGHTEEN CHINA BY THE YEAR. TWO
THOUSAND PANDA TWENTY TWO
WITNESS THANK YOU WE LIKE YOUR
TEA AND YOU LIKE OUR COFFEE YES
EH THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT.
YES THEY ALSO WE'VE BEEN WE'VE
BEEN SITUATION WE ARE IN THE
SAME BOAT A ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION.
PEOPLE THANK YOU.
SO SO WE SAY HERE IN THE
LANGUAGE ACTUALLY --
RESOLVED BY THE ASSEMBLY IN THIS
SENATE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA JOINT LEAD THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ACTIVELY SUPPORTS
CONTINUED COORDINATION AND
COLLABORATION BETWEEN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC OF
CHINA TO INCREASE MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL --
RELATIONSHIP OR OPPORTUNITIES TO
STRAIGHT THEN THE OUR BILATERAL
RELATIONSHIP IN AREAS OF PEOPLE
TO PEOPLE EXCHANGE TRADE CLIMATE
CHANGE EDUCATION TOURISM
TECHNOLOGY.
ON INNOVATION AND GREEN
DEVELOPMENT AND I WANTED TO READ
THAT WE USUALLY DON'T DO THAT
BUT NOW WITH SO MANY THINGS
HAPPENING.
IN THE WORLD AND EVEN AT THE SAN
THAT.
WE CALIFORNIA LOCATED ON THE
WEST COAST AND A WHERE YOU ARE
LOCATED IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
RELATIONSHIP BUT WE WANT TO
CONTINUE FOCUS ON IT I THINK
SOME OF OUR MEMBERS.
MAYBE WOULD LIKE TO TRAVEL THERE
SOMEDAY AND AND SEE FIRSTHAND
WHAT DO WE HAVE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
ANY COMMENTS BEFORE WE GO AHEAD
LIST TO THE ROLL CALL FIRST AND
THEN WE'RE READY.
CHECK QUIRK SILVA.
HERE.
TOOK WORKS OVER HERE BY SIR ALAN.
BERMAN HERE BERMAN HERE
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES HERE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ HERE STEINORTH
[inaudible]
STEINORTH HERE.
BUT I'M CHAIR WE HAVE QUAN.
ALRIGHT SO ANY COMMENTS BEFORE.
BUT A MOTION A SECOND ANY OTHER
COMMENTS AND THEN WE ASKED FOR A
THOSE IN SUPPORT ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
AND THOSE OPPOSED.
CASEY NOT NONE WILL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE THE BOAT.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AJ ARE FORTY
FOURTH MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED RECOMMEND CONSENT CHAIR
QUIRK SILVA.
AYE CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AYE VICE
CHAIR ALAN [inaudible]
VICE.
BERMAN I'VE BERMAN AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE STEINORTH
[inaudible]
STEINORTH I UP WE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW MINUTES.
FIVE MINUTES ANDA OTHERWISE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
YOU AGAIN YEAH THANK I THANK
EVERYBODY THINK OF CHINA WE
ALWAYS BE THAT GOOD PART IN ALL
OF YEAH CALIFORNIA AND THE VIDEO
CO SPONSORS A CLIMATE CHANGE
SUMMIT WITH THE GOVERNOR.
AND NEXT MONTH YES WHERE YOU'RE
GOING NEXT MONTH THEN IRENE HERE
HERE LIVING SOME VERSUS SCHOOL
SUMMER IT'S IT'S BILL WITH YOUR
HOST THAT --
RECEPTION FULL THE PARTICIPANTS.
YEAH I THINK IT [inaudible]
OKAY OKAY.
NICE TO SEE YOU.
I'M SURE.
WALMART BECAUSE I'M HERE AGAIN
HI JEFF.
ABOVE OKAY LETTERS.
NUMBER THAT WERE INTRODUCED
PASSED GAS.
OKAY WELL WITH [inaudible]
A GREAT.
YOU KNOW I DID BRING MY WALLET
METHODOLOGY [inaudible]
EXTENSION.
VERY SLOW AT JENNIFER'S A FRIDAY
NIGHT SO.
NOT ONLY DOES HAVE BEEN
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THIS AT A FRIGHTENING
PREMONITION YEAH LET US
[inaudible]
WHY [inaudible]
LOADING [inaudible]
WELL GOOD [inaudible]
BERMAN. THREE IS THERE YOU GET A
LITTLE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE YOU.
THURMOND ONE HEARING. ONE RIGHT
[inaudible]
GREG HAD YOU VERY MUCH.
THE OFFICE HAS A HISTORY OF
ALZHEIMER'S DATA
.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE --
AJ ARE FORTY FOUR THAT WILL MOVE
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR IN IT IS
OUT